a dangerous virus is spreading rapidly
in China and US officials are very
worried that it could come here China
has more than 200 confirmed cases of
corona virus it's called which produces
pneumonia like symptoms three people
have already died from this illness
which has spread to at least three other
Asian countries new video sent to CBS
News claims to show hospital staff
wearing protective gear and that is
protective gear in Wuhan China
considered ground zero for the outbreak
Ramey innocencio is there Ramey
what are you hearing good morning Gail
yes people here are understandably very
nervous especially after the number of
infected exploded over the weekend the
airport here in Wuhan has also started
to do body temperature checks of people
before they take flight not only that
when we landed here in Wuhan earlier
today we saw people many of them wearing
masks around the baggage carousel while
we were waiting for own bags I took that
video there and you can see and people
are nervous about the situation not only
that taking a look at what's happening
in the United States US officials want
to make sure that they are raising the
defenses and that is what they are doing
there because right now as of now there
has not been a u.s. infection as of yet
at three airports across the United
States the CDC is on guard more than 100
officials in San Francisco Los Angeles
and New York are screening incoming
passengers from Wuhan China to detect
the deadly coronavirus if it's issues
that the corner affects others it
would be good choices to like cash knows
about it since Friday the number of
known infections across Asia has more
than quadrupled with cases confirmed in
China Thailand Japan and now South Korea
which reported its first case this
morning authorities say most of the
cases linked back to this now shuttered
animal and seafood market in Wuhan US
health officials are concerned this
rapid spread could mimic the massive
SARS outbreak of the early 2000s which
resulted in 774 deaths in 29 countries
but so far it does not appear that this
disease is easily transmittable between
people health officials say this strain
of the corona virus has been spread to
humans through exposure in handling of
animals at the market if the virus turns
out to be readily transmissible from
human to human then we'll have a much
larger problem on our hand dr. William
Schaffner says public health authorities
are already working on ways to fend off
the epidemic there are laboratories
around the world already working on
really good diagnostic tests and we've
already started to work on a vaccine in
the event that's necessary
now I lived through the SARS epidemic in
Beijing back in 2003 and at that time
there was massive criticism of the
government and that centered around
transparency the government at that time
withheld a lot of information from the
public about that massively growing
epidemic now that we're gonna see if
this is actually gonna be any lessons
have been learned
looking ahead because the future of the
people of China and not only of Asia but
of the world it could be at stake here
mpany yeah hopefully they'll be more
forthcoming Remy thank you in China we
appreciate it